both have the same tech people running
the show
i mean i'm oh listen i i apologize but
also i'm not surprised that would happen
to trump right well you know he he he
probably doesn't know how to run
i think here he is again oh he's back i
think he's back they don't even know how
to use tech i mean you know what i don't
like to be on the tommy lahren show
anyway like who
hello oh yeah yes i i i'm here i'm here
uh grandpa
i thought it was tommy you know no no no
no no
oh is that why your mic was not was not
you know what i think maybe that was
that was the case i was connected to the
other show but but i'm here now and
that's and that's so so where are you
you look like you're on some sort of uh
tacky ass where are you are you are you
i'm in mar-a-lago but i don't need you
guys to see how it looks right now
melania had to fire the cleaning lady
because we deported her
oh you deported her why did you deport
her i mean i thought you were
hiring illegal immigrants but i mean
you're against everyone else but you're
for yourself having illegal immigrants
right
i can't really comment on that right now
but oh is that right is that right well
let's see if gabe has any questions for
you do you know do you know our producer
and co-host gabe you know he looks a
little familiar he looks like my son but
that's all i'll say about that my
favorite i don't i don't know if i
should take that as a compliment or i
meant
[Laughter]
those are fighting words so so if that's
how you classify as a fight so former
guy former guy let me ask you you had a
route you had a nazi uh rally this
weekend that you went to um and there
was there was a lot of uh [ __ ] going
on at your alley they really worship you
out there like you're some kind of god
or jesus or something i i call you mango
mango mussolini jesus um are you saying
sort of jesus to these people
and you're well you know what i don't
like to talk about well i do religion is
between you and god so i mean if that's
the way they see me well then that's the
way they see me folks am i right
yeah you're uh you're right who's is
there someone else in the room that
you're talking to
i can't disclose that information oh
okay so let's talk about your comments
that you made on stage because you said
that you wanted to pardon all these uh
these seditious criminals uh a lot of
them are charged with sedition's
conspiracy so you're wanting to pardon
are you wanting to pardon them so you
can save your own ass because it sounds
like you would love to run to save your
own ass it's not about me it's about the
american people and those people from
january 6 once i'm reinstated or if i
have to run again in 2024 i will treat
those january 6 people very fairly very
fairly you know what they're not being
treated very they're not being treated
very nicely by that unselect committee
it's more of a witch hunt if you ask me
so it sounds like it sounds like um
you're trying to preempt that if maybe
you or someone else you know that you
know might have to go be a quote-unquote
political prisoner as you you called him
um it sounds like you're trying to make
sure that you're treated fairly when
you're actually when your asses in the
ring are here you know it's not about me
like i said
get it through your thick skull it's
about the american people and that's all
i really care about but since we're
talking about it since you're talking
about me you should buy my new book
trump poetry you can check it out it's
on amazon it's only a hundred and sixty
two dollars 162
wow
is it like a [ __ ]
what about the picture book that you uh
that you well that that's a that's back
ordered and you know that's that's a
great coffee table book melania helped
me put that together and we're just you
know we're very proud of it oh i i'm i'm
sure i'm sure you're proud of the
coloring book that you're releasing that
time i don't know it's a picture book oh
is it like is it also is it like a
pop-up picture book too yes exactly oh
right yeah the coloring book comes out
next month so there's so there's another
griff next month there's the grip this
month the griff next month then so stay
tuned oh okay okay well so i i also want
to ask you and i know gabe is probably
interested in this dude the statement
that you released i think it was
yesterday how you uh blatantly said that
you tried to overturn the government of
the united states how do you respond to
making you know you you said it out loud
yeah you said the quiet part of that guy
what's going on well i mean it's it's
not very quiet because mike pence
he had the absolute right to overturn
the election and i mean i've said that
plenty of times it's now just written
down on paper so i don't really see you
liberals gaining anything here you know
what i mean you know the senate is
trying to change the rules the democrats
and the rhino republicans specifically
wacky susan collins we all don't like
her you know if they're trying to pass
legislation that will allow the vice
president that won't allow the vice
president to change the election that
means mike pence could have done it
that's all i was just pointing out the
facts the real news unlike you the fake
news i'm going to say this though i do
have to i this might be the only time i
ever agree with trump
i also don't like wacky susan collins
[ __ ] her yeah you know what we can we
can agree on that i think that's i think
that's we can all right we can all agree
on that uh who are you talking to yeah
are you talking to someone there at
mar-a-lago is there someone there you
know i we we can't really we can't
really go into oh okay okay well i i do
have one thing i want to say about what
you um what you just said is that the
vice president united states has the
possibility to overturn
the the uh election so what does that
does that mean in 2024 even if you would
win that kamala harris can just make
sure that joe biden's device are the
president united states that's what i'm
hearing and i mean so i mean really
honestly what what the [ __ ] is the point
of running and what the [ __ ] is well you
know what sony camelot phony camera let
me tell you a little bit about her we're
all you know she could change the
election and we have to make sure that
doesn't happen because we're going to
take them out we're going to destroy a
pardon anyone i'll pardon anyone but you
know what the real problem is everyone
here is talking about ukraine and you
know what i support ukraine fully i
support ukraine oh i mean uh i support
ukraine i really do oh that was a
russian flag that was already this is
the ukrainian flag i don't know what you
mean
you know the border crisis that's going
on in ukraine is nothing compared to
what's going on in mexico down on our
southern border i built a wall i built a
beautiful wall and so so that was creepy
excuse me excuse me i'm talking sleepy
no sleepy joe has done nothing
nothing
nothing okay so so back to russia and
ukraine because it does seem like you
are a little your boyfriend putin um is
trying to test is trying to test the
president because he didn't need to test
you it sounds like he had you in his
back pocket i mean you got his flag
there you're waving it around
what
putin your boyfriend yeah poutine
excuse i'm getting a phone call one
second hello hello yeah
no no i'm vlad it's it's not a good time
uh i'll call you back oh no uh
you know
he's not my people so is he listening is
he listening to the show right now
no no no he's not listening he doesn't
have me on a title is this is this
streaming to some russian tv station out
there now
uh i don't know you tell me you guys are
the fake news
you know crimes against ukraine
oh ukraine
yes
i i thought you were in bed with putin
do you mean to say crimes against the
kremlin like what do you want uh you
know you take interpret it however you
like
oh well okay
i i appreciate you um
you you coming we're gonna have to uh uh
jump out here because you know
you know what i i it's time for me to
listen to my calming music anyway
and you know it was just it's been a
great time for some but you know it's
just i have a very busy schedule
mm-hmm yeah everybody
what the hell could possibly be on your
schedule we have to decide if i'm
running again in 2024 oh wait if i had
to be reinstated as president even sir
because we need to stop the radical
liberal left sleepy joe and of course
county camelot do you really want to
live in there america we need to make
america great again
again and again
and again when was it when was it not
great when was america not great the
specifics of your question will have to
go through uh other channels
so before you go uh
if you run or are reinstated because
clearly you don't really like pence that
much you know
um right well who's gonna be
who's gonna who's gonna be the vp who's
the writer no i don't you know it's it
there's there's a lot of um a lot of
names going around you know of course
mike pence if he wants to be on the
ticket we'll put him on the ticket but
you know what maybe there's someone
better but you know ron desantis i
thought he was good i thought he was
good until he decided that he might want
to run for president so i got to take
him down i got to cut him off at the
knees if you get what i mean and if
anyone you know wants to i'll pause
harding okay i'll pardon them too
whatever
oh okay so so you're you're flashing
more pardons for more violence we get it
we get we we get the uh the fascist
tinger again we have to go um whether
you like it or not so
well i have to go because i'm very busy
so you know what
i you know this has been fun and all but
next time don't pretend you're tommy
laron tony you know what this is just
really rude of you and and
and i have no time for this in the
future
wow
wow
there we go he just what just happened i
was there no idea that was uh that was
something else yeah well you know um i
guess i guess when you book
an interview with the cheeto dust
monster that's what you get i i didn't
even know you know i i thought maybe i
could put this request and then this
request would come true i'm gonna oh i
hope we are able to get uh more
politicians or former politicians yeah
on the show you know
yeah i was gonna say knowing how
narcissistic and egotistical there i
wouldn't be surprised if they just
wanted more screen time right right i'm
sure yeah i'm sure but what did you
think of this um
the former guy here the cheeto dust
mobster some of the things that he said
this weekend and
how he responded here
he's
he is slowly uh unraveling and revealing
his
his true core his true intentions right
uh
i mean
like you you said you know you sent me i
saw the statement but you sent it to me
and i read it and i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was like how do i mean
you mean yesterday yeah yeah you sent me
this the the the release the
announcement or press release that trump
did
and i was like i
i don't even think i can outdo this yeah
you even said you like can can i make
this even better i'm like no no yeah i
was like can i
can i not gonna work no i can't because
here's the thing he said it the only the
only correction that i joked about was
if i sent a follow-up press release and
i was like
uh i've been told that what i said was
not what i should have said so let me
just
uh follow up by saying hypothetically
if i were
[Laughter]
because this is this is the craziest
part about what happened this weekend is
not only did he go on stage and outright
say we i want to to commit sedition but
then this [ __ ] [ __ ] says not only do
i want to commit morris edition but that
sedition that you saw that's exactly
what it was it was exactly that it was
exactly sedition all this stuff that
you're seeing these people being charged
with i'm gonna have to pardon them if
you want me to because that's the only
way they're going to get out of this
because we did like he's literally
saying we committed sedition and they're
going to be charged and go to prison for
it and the only way out of it is if you
elect me so i can pardon them from the
[ __ ] crime of treason right that's
what he's saying it out loud like why
can't you people realize he's not just
talking about pardoning people who love
him that's not what he's saying what
he's saying is
we tried to overthrow the government in
the united states people are to go to
federal prison because of it and
because of that the only way to get
these people out of it is to elect me so
i can party because no one else is going
to do that there's no one else out there
that is going to pardon these people
from the crime of trying to overturn the
conflict i i think about that and i say
you know that also might backfire right
for the for the
for the subjects that he's targeting
which is like j6 all these people that
are you know uh potentially going to
prison or time or whatever that need to
get pardoned
you know at this point do those people
be like okay i'm i'm not gonna fight
this anymore or like rather i am going
to fight this
and then put themselves in a more
terrible situation so that they're
they're they don't even they're just
like oh i'm not guilty i'm not guilty i
didn't do it
and then they're like well here all the
crimes and you're not gonna try and do a
plea deal
you're [ __ ] right are they gonna hold
out with like you know their hard-headed
stubborn behavior and then just
ultimately get [ __ ] over because
they're believing that a crazy man right
is going to then save them if he is
reinstated or reelected in 2024. in
other words go to prison for me now
when when all the supporters support me
and put me in power and i will pardon
hundreds of you which he had the chance
to do this already like
this isn't the first time he promised to
do this and i think that's the thing
here i think that's i think that's the
thing that not only his supporters but
the rest of the country isn't seeing is
a lot of these january 6 defendants that
are going to go to prison for him
because that's what that's what's
happening they're going to go to prison
for him and for crimes that they
committed in his name to make him
dictator um here's the thing
is they're probably pissed off that he
didn't take the chance to pardon him why
yeah you know so are you are they gonna
take him seriously i you know i don't
know i guess that's the question i think
that's what you're trying to say is hey
don't tell on me don't rat on me because
you know just sit tight for a few years
and you know and then i'll go
right it's kind of like when you're in
like you like let's say you meet your
partner and they're like i'm not ready
yet just wait you know and they're like
how long am i waiting they're like i
don't know and then you're like it's all
in hopes
that you know they're gonna be like okay
i'm ready to now have this relationship
or or like if i had a business
opportunity they're gonna say
um
okay just give me like 6 to 12 months as
i set up shop and then i will
you know hire you or whatever it is
which is a super long [ __ ] time away
right especially to put just blind faith
into someone that has so far led you
astray and and
and not helped you out i mean literally
trump had 14 days
or i guess 13 days to do whatever he
wanted do something
what he did he did he pardoned all his
[ __ ] puppets right right yeah as
puppets that he needed to to make sure
to extend the propaganda because that's
what's happening is he's extending this
propaganda and he used mike flynn roger
stone you know all these people to
extend his propaganda before we go to
the interview with missy which everyone
should stick around because it's a great
interview it's great trivia we had a
great time with missy modell um
so stick around for that interview it's
going to come up right after this but i
want to ask you about one more thing
because this is this is really
this is this is the dumb [ __ ] me and
rachel talked about it here a second ago
i'm going to show you the statement here
here's the official statement from that
dumb [ __ ] and everyone's like don't post
this don't give him a platform i'm like
look i don't post his statements i don't
post his [ __ ] statements that are
absolute garbage and irrelevant because
he's irrelevant but he is he is
admitting right out loud what he did
january 6 and what their intentions were
that's why i posted it and if you don't
like it unfollow me block me mute me
whatever there's all kinds of cool
things you can do on the twitter app to
make sure you don't see this statement
but weak eyes are not is what's going to
save our democracy we have we have to
know like the nazis down in orlando
florida you need to go look at those
[ __ ] banners that's their plan that's
what they want the let's go brandon is
now nazi [ __ ] it is and we need to tie
that let's go brandon stuff to nazis
everyone out there on twitter ever when
you're in your community say hey that
let's go brandon thing that's nazi
propaganda that's nazi propaganda it's
proof in florida here's a video here's a
picture we need to put it in front of
people like like rachel said make memes
anyone who's making memes out there
[ __ ] cue them up and start spreading
that [ __ ] around because we have to we
have to fight because they want they
want the people um
down in florida who showed up and i
think you posted a picture of these uh
these names oh yeah did these ninja boot
nazis are that going but they are
serious that's who they want in charge
but um now on this statement um
obviously he's wanting to overturn it
but then again underneath your crawl
when these people understand that
daylight is the best disinfectant it
gets in my [ __ ] i'm like people look
you just you can't not look away from
stuff that's super important and the
important part is they want a fascist
state and they're saying it out loud
they're saying it out loud you can't
ignore this [ __ ] the thing is like if
you ignore this stuff you know for all
the people who i you know and i agree
with you uh i've had you know similar
people have come at me and they're like
oh stop stop sharing this stuff or even
like when i made the the the parody one
right and it went viral and people like
stop sharing and stop sharing it and
it's like okay one i'm making fun of
this idiot but two there are really
important things that are being said
here right he is saying the quiet part
out loud in print on the internet
right don't ignore it if you ignore it
then you're gonna then be that person
that says oh that's so crazy he wouldn't
do that he wouldn't say that like no
wait no way would donald trump get
elected in 2016 right right yeah yeah
it's that type of just you know
just you put the blinders on because
you're like
because what it is is
people will write comments on videos i
make either the people on the side that
were support trump or like oh you're
obsessed with trump and i'm like you're
the [ __ ] that's trying to get them
reinstated or
whatever the hell it is so shut the [ __ ]
up but then there's the other side which
is on the left where people are like oh
stop amplifying or platforming i'm like
listen one i'm a small account two he's
a big [ __ ] person in that party and
three he's not going anywhere he's
established himself as part of the
establishment now
right is the republican party
going forward if you're not with trump
then you're against the republican party
is essentially what it is right look at
what happened to liz cheney and adam
kingsinger right the only ones brave
enough the only fascists brave enough to
pick up the shovel to try to bury
trumpism so they can get their old you
know thin veiled fascism back they're
old they get voted out right the [ __ ]
they get out of leadership adam king
just can't even run
this is what happens and the left is
like oh these are heroes and and it just
it it you know they're ready they're
ready for a fascist state and if you
don't believe it go listen to what we
just watched rachel say and really go
subscribe to the youtube channel because
rachel's over there i i think it's like
the third this is the third time she's
been on the third time she's been on we
did we did an over an hour interview
with her last week we talked about
strategic outrage this week we talked
about this this fascism at the forefront
and and how we can use this as our
weapon like this is this is ammunition
that they're giving us to fight this the
fight of democracy like we can do this
we can use this the same way they use
the [ __ ] crt [ __ ] that voodoo we
can use this as a national [ __ ]
narrative and make it look local to have
strategic outrage because we have to
stay pissed we have to go [ __ ] vote
because really when it comes to
democracy
democrats are the only party that want
to deliver democracy republicans not
only want to destroy it but their plan
is to absolutely 100 percent destroy it
we've seen the video of the guy saying
unplug the voting machines and bring
your gun you pee pew i mean they want to
destroy democracy yeah and they want to
do it in a very very violent manner i'm
i'm i'm really excited about this
interview with missy um
not not to switch subjects so quickly
but we need to get to it but um stick
around because this interview she
actually you know we were talking about
trolls and stuff and people being
comments um she actually talks a little
bit about mental health on social media
talking about how it can affect you you
know it does have a wide effect when
people are in your comments saying these
things um you know taking breaks and
missy explains it really well and and of
course her her parody uh songs are
[ __ ] just absolutely fantastic yeah
if you're not following her over on tick
tock and instagram i know she posts some
stuff on twitter so go follow her on on
all those places but her her parody
songs are fantastic um john walsh uh who
may or may not have been trump in the
last little bit there
when i told him that we were doing the
interview he's like the missy model i'm
like yeah the davis so he was super
excited um and john does great content
himself so you know that missy uh missy
has it all lined up so stick around uh
don't miss this don't miss this
interview we'll be right back with the
missy model interview stay right here
after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]